[Música]
escala en París ahí da Palau
Bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio Francia internacional y France 24
la universidad Parisina saodón Nobel ha
nombrado doctora honoris causa a la
opositora nicaragüense Dora María Téllez
actualmente en la prisión el chipote
donde cumple una condena de 8 años el
encargado de representarla en París ha
sido el reconocido periodista Carlos
Fernando Chamorro barrios quien ha sido
tan amable de hacer esta escala en París
muchísimas gracias y bienvenido bueno
primero de todo un comentario sobre esta
insignia doctor honoris causa de la
sorbona Dora María Téllez de 68 años
historiadora
guerrillera sandinista ex ministra de
salud y luchó como muchos disidentes al
lado de Ortega contra La dictadura
sandinista antes de desencantarse Qué
significa este reconocimiento de París
Bueno es un reconocimiento a una mujer
extraordinaria de ideas y de acción que
representa yo diría lo mejor de la
izquierda democrática en América Latina
Dora María Téllez ha sido consecuente a
lo largo de su vida con la lucha por la
justicia social y la democracia pero
sobre todo es una mujer que ha roto con
muchos esquemas feministas
Audaz por su participación primero como
guerrillera después en la resistencia
cívica y hoy es un símbolo de la
resistencia a la dictadura de Daniel
Ortega tiene
533 días de estar en una celda de
confinamiento Solitario en la cárcel del
chipote acaba de hacer una huelga de
hambre de 19 días y se mantiene firme
como ese símbolo de resistencia
recordemos que fue arrestada en junio de
2021 verdad en esa ola de arrestos una
ola masiva no de contra opositores lo
comentábamos antes periodistas políticos
estudiantes
empresarios muchos de esos opositores
además se iban a presentar a las
elecciones eran precandidatos
cómo se encuentra de salud la señora
Téllez creo que está en una celda
aislada como muchos otros ha podido
hablar con ella
es imposible hablar con ella y con los
precios de chipote solamente tienen
derecho a una visita familiar cada 40 50
días la última visita ocurrió en un
lapso de 85 días y no existe ninguna
posibilidad de de comunicación Es verdad
que las familias los familiares se
quejan no de que no pueden visitarlos
estaba Ortega vulnerando también el
derecho de los presos o de las familias
de los presos los derechos de ambos en
la cárcel del chipote los presos no
tienen derecho ni a leer ni a escribir
no existe un libro un papel y un lápiz
ni siquiera una Biblia como suele haber
en todas las cárceles es una cárcel de
tortura de aislamiento de destrucción de
los seres humanos y a pesar de eso hay
que destacar la resistencia de Dora
María de otras tres compañeras que están
en celdas de confinamiento solitario y
de muchos otros después de las últimas
leyes contra ongs por ejemplo hay Alguna
algún organismo que puede entrar a esa
prisión para ver cómo están ninguno y
nunca entraba a esa cárcel ni siquiera
la Cruz Roja Internacional las
comisiones internacionales de derechos
humanos de la oea y la ONU todas han
demandado que se abra la cárcel al
escrutinio precisamente para verificar
las condiciones de salud física y mental
y emocional de los presos políticos y ha
habido una negativa total de parte del
régimen Es un régimen de crueldad y de
venganza no hay ninguna otra explicación
la represión comienza en 2018 con esas
revueltas y una respuesta feroz de las
autoridades también fue el inicio de los
ataques a la prensa con una censura
inédita medios que tuvieron que cerrar
creo que hay más de 40 medios
audiovisuales
censurados
usted que dirige el diario El
confidencial es su fundador ha tenido
que exiliarse a Costa Rica En qué estado
se encuentra la prensa de su país No es
fácil trabajar supongo no es posible hoy
hacer periodismo en Nicaragua hacemos
periodismo desde el exilio y yo diría
que es la última libertad que se
mantiene vigente porque estamos libres
no estamos silenciados mi redacción fue
ocupada por la policía el 14 de
diciembre de 2018 también 100% noticias
y el año pasado el diario de la prensa
es decir hay tres medios confiscados más
de 40 medios cerrados más de 150
periodistas en el exilio
ocho personas vinculadas a medios de
comunicación en la cárcel entre ellos mi
hermana cristiana que también era
precandidata presidencial Juan Lorenzo
holman el gerente de la prensa Miguel
Mora director de cien por ciento
noticias y precandidato presidencial y
el bloguero y periodista deportivo
Miguel Mendoza y varios más de manera
que la prensa sobrevive desde el exilio
y hay una criminalización también de la
libertad de opinión en Nicaragua Hay
personas que están en la cárcel porque
brindaron una entrevista a un medio de
comunicación o porque postearon una
opinión en redes sociales usted forma
parte de una saga familiar que ha dado
varios presidentes a Nicaragua es el
hijo de Violeta barrios que presidió el
país entre el 90 y el 96 como decía su
hermana cristiana precandidata a la
presidencia está en arresto domiciliario
así como su hermano Joaquín y tiene dos
primos en la cárcel Ortega ha conseguido
aniquilar a la oposición en Nicaragua
bueno la ha aplastado en la medida en
que todo el liderazgo de la oposición
entre esos 225 presos políticos Yo diría
que hay unas cuarenta cincuenta personas
que representan el liderazgo político y
el liderazgo Cívico también hay líderes
empresariales estudiantes universitarios
líderes campesinos y cívicos y sin
embargo no ha podido
establecer digamos El dominio sobre la
población en Nicaragua hay silencio hay
temor Pero hay una mayoría política que
rechaza el régimen y quiere un cambio se
vive bajo un estado policial no hay
libertad de reunión ni libertad de
movilización de manera que prácticamente
hay una anulación de la posibilidad de
hacer política y también de la
posibilidad de desarrollar el espacio
cívico de la sociedad civil que ha sido
anulada incluso la iglesia ha sido
atacada yo no sé si hay otros ejemplos
en otros países pero los sacerdotes en
la cárcel obispos hay gente que se ha
tenido que exiliar de la iglesia porque
el régimen Ortega Murillo ataca a la
iglesia nicaragüense porque la iglesia
se convirtió en el último espacio
digamos de las posibilidades de
desarrollar alguna actividad cívica en
el país y me refiero a la iglesia que se
solidariza con las víctimas de la de la
represión y de las violaciones a los
derechos humanos en Nicaragua hubo
primero una matanza hay 325 asesinatos
en la impunidad luego hubo una represión
la imposición del Estado policial la
anulación de la vida electoral Y por
último el cierre total del espacio
Cívico faltaba la iglesia hay hay
obispos en el exilio hay sacerdotes en
el exilio y se llevó al extremo incluso
de prohibir las procesiones religiosas
Simplemente porque la dictadura no
quiere que los nicaragüenses se reúnan y
puedan salir a las calles de de
cualquier forma
a pesar de toda esta oposición contra
este régimen el régimen se mantiene Cuál
es la explicación Por qué este régimen
se mantiene en el poder el control de la
represión de la policía de los
paramilitares la cooptación del ejército
Ese es el principal Pilar hay un
malestar creciente dentro de los
funcionarios públicos dentro de los
servidores públicos civiles y militares
pero pero hay otra realidad los
nicaragüenses están saliendo del país
masivamente hay un Éxodo hacia Estados
Unidos y hacia Costa Rica a su vez
envían remesas familiares Que alimentan
irónicamente la economía nicaragüense de
manera que sí el régimen se ha sostenido
durante estos cuatro años uno puede
concluir de que un sistema así no es
sostenible a largo plazo pero sí puede
prolongar esto que yo siempre he
considerado que es una enfermedad
terminal una enfermedad política
terminal de autoritario hay disidencia
recientes Porque muchos regímenes de
este tipo se caen desde dentro No desde
fuera
hay malestar hay disidencia interna hay
funcionarios del régimen que han sido
encarcelados otros simplemente renuncian
y se van algunos también han desertado
públicamente Pero yo no creo que el
régimen se derrumbe solo se va a caer
como resultado de un incremento de la
presión externa y de la presión interna
se necesita Por tanto la liberación de
los presos políticos Ese es el primer
paso liberar a los presos políticos es
la premisa para la liberación de
Nicaragua el régimen solo no se derrumba
y si se puede prolongar habla de la
presión externa ha habido sanciones
desde países como Estados Unidos o el
bloque europeo son suficientes las
sanciones han estado enfocadas en
individuos en más de 50 altos
funcionarios del régimen civiles y
militares y en algunas instituciones
específicas como la policía la fiscalía
no no hay un embargo económico no son
sanciones que hayan afectado a la
población nicaragüense yo creo que se
requiere de un aislamiento total del
régimen y hace falta que muchos otros
países de América Latina se sumen países
que mantienen una relación de cierta
ambigüedad y complacencia con la
dictadura de Ortega puedo mencionar a
México a Honduras a de alguna forma
Argentina Bolivia en cambio otro
gobierno de la izquierda democrática de
América Latina como como Boris de chile
claramente ha dicho no se puede tolerar
la existencia de una dictadura en nombre
de la izquierda no se puede aceptar
dictaduras que violan los Derechos
Humanos creo que esa es la misma
posición de Petro en Colombia y hay una
gran expectativa sobre qué posición va a
adoptar el nuevo presidente de Brasil
Lula Silva justamente hablando del
presidente chileno Gabriel Boris dijo y
tras esas elecciones municipales no tras
conocerse el resultado de que bueno el
partido oficialista había conseguido
todas las alcaldías dijo un proceso
electoral que se realiza sin Libertad
Justicia electoral confiable y
opositores presos o proscritos no es
democracia en ninguna parte del mundo
Espera que estos cambios que ha habido
justamente en Brasil en Colombia y en
Chile puede hacer cambiar la situación
en Nicaragua
deberían deberían representar un
incremento de la posición de los
gobiernos de América Latina la solución
a la crisis de Nicaragua está en Managua
no está en Bruselas no está en
Washington no está en otros países Pero
insisto para eso se necesita
restablecer las libertades democráticas
en Nicaragua y eso comienza por la
liberación de los presos políticos qué
piensa del Silencio de algunos
intelectuales latinoamericanos de
izquierda no sobre lo que ocurre en
Nicaragua muchos siempre están súper
alerta cuando violación de Derechos
Humanos en muchos países pero cuando se
trata de gobiernos de izquierda pues tal
vez la crítica no la condena pues se les
hace más difícil no de hacer Yo diría
que eso ha cambiado mucho y que la
mayoría de los intelectuales
latinoamericanos y los movimientos
políticos están claros de que Nicaragua
lo que hay es una tiranía una un régimen
represivo igual que la que lo que fue la
dictadura de somoza antes de 1979 quedan
algunos grupos que están alineados
también al ortodoxia a la dictadura de
Venezuela la dictadura de Cuba pero en
su mayoría la izquierda democrática Yo
diría que está sumándose a reconocer que
no se puede tener un doble estándar con
una dictadura como la de Nicaragua pues
muchísimas gracias Señor Carlos Fernando
Chamorro barrios ya no nos queda mucho
tiempo y le dejamos lo mejor para usted
para y para el periodismo nicaragüense y
a ver si se libera no a esos presos
políticos Muchísimas gracias gracias a
ustedes y gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir también por internet en rf
y mundo.com y en France 24.com Hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]